who would I like to not actually we can
do this I think the most important step
to grow in conversation is not adding
the number of mouths but increasing
number of years I mean I'm wondering to
talk i am one of the thought but but but
i actually think that that some of the
most important things we can do is is is
listen better i am still moved by oh
gosh i'm going to forget the name of the
guy why can't we all get along that guy
in California rodney brown is that the
name I think rot rodney brown who sort
of plaintively said why can't we all get
along and it seems to me that that the
question is not so much who we should be
talking to but who should be listening
and how much how much more listening
should we be doing I'm either be a lot
of people I would want to to talk to and
they would many of them not be the usual
suspects I mean that would be part of my
job part of what i'm trying to do would
be to try to find people who were not
the usual suspects when people talk
about business ethics for example a not
insignificant issue they too often talk
to people who are safe or retired or
already rich and what I want to talk to
about business ethics I want to talk to
somebody who's got a college tuition and
a mortgage to pay and a boss who asks in
to cut corners and so I want to talk to
people who actually have some skin in
the game of some of these decisions
whether their health care decisions or
ethical decisions or or political
decisions and they may not be experts
and so you don't necessarily want to
talk to them for their expertise you
want to talk to them for what for what's
making it hard to try to figure out then
what is the expertise you want to bring
around that so I think that's what I
do I would try to find the people who
are in the middle of these issues and
and and not and go to them to try to
attempt to understand what the dynamic
is in their lives and these are not
described a couple of issues where they
might be ouchy issues where I'm hurt I'm
depressed but you might also try to find
somebody who is on the cusp of greatness
or is doing really exciting things and
say all right what's holding you back
was making it possible where did it come
from what's got you going about this and
just just just just just listen and try
to then pick up things that other people
might might then the people listening to
them might say oh that's interesting
I've got an idea for how to do something
with that or around that that's what I
do